this is the hill house in southwest
scotland it was built in 1902 using
design and construction techniques that
were years ahead of their time it's an
important bit of architectural history
but because it was years ahead of its
time it was also experimental it turns
out that the house exterior just soaks
up all the heavy scottish rains and lets
the water in 120 years after it was
built this whole building is slowly
cracking and crumbling and dissolving
the first step of saving this house is
to dry it out slowly and carefully the
problem is it rains 190 days a year
around here so the national trust for
scotland had to build a very big drying
room the hill house is so important it
is globally known we attract visitors
from all over the world and a pilgrimage
to come and visit the hill house charles
jenny mcintosh is definitely one of
scotland's most famous architects and
designers it is macintosh's domestic
masterpiece it really is so ahead of its
time when you walk through the front
door when you picture what was
essentially a victorian family living in
this house she realized how
forward-thinking macintosh was in his
design he used a material called
portland cement on the exterior there
was no lime at all used on site as well
or located in one of the wettest parts
of scotland in helensborough so it
really was a recipe for disaster the
hellhouse has been described as
dissolving like an aspirin and a glass
of water the box basically buys us some
time to dry the house out shelter it
from around 86
of the elements it acts like a giant
umbrella and shields the house from the
weather the walls of this box are made
of chain mail if you go and order a
modern armor costume with a chain mail
vest it will be made of this same stuff
it's more than 30 million rings of
stainless steel linked together weighing
eight tons the roof catches most of the
rain and the chain mail catches what
blows in from the sides but it also lets
air through for ventilation it lets bees
and other insects through to pollinate
the plants in here and it's all
recyclable afterwards because it's steel
you just melt it down into something
else the box is made up of 32.4 million
individual chainmail links that surround
the house and the world's largest sheet
of chainmail in terms of construction it
took nine months it really is one of a
kind it cost around four and a half
million pounds if you were to cover the
house completely it would be at risk of
suffering from environmental shock and
it would cause more damage than good the
box still allows the house to breathe
that's really important it would dry out
too quickly it would cause damage to the
exterior and indeed to the collection
inside the property as well
before you'd be able to visit the house
and it was here on its own and it was
amazing but the box adds another level
there are walkways all around the
property you can walk around the
perimeter of the house even up and over
the top seeing the house from aspects
that macintosh himself would never even
have seen what you're seeing at the hill
house is conservation and action they
didn't need to add the staircases and
gantries and ramps here but if you block
this house from public view for the 15
years it'll take to dry out and repair
then there's a chance the public are
going to forget about it it'll look like
a construction site an eyesore if
instead you highlight it you create
something one of a kind like this box
and you let the public see the house
from angles that will likely never be
possible again well then you're not just
preserving important architecture you're
promoting it and for me that's the
cleverest part of all this i wouldn't be
here you wouldn't be watching this if it
wasn't for the box
it was built in 1902
there's one more step i thought that was
there